[Music]
along with rising temperatures something
else is heating up this summer it's a
battle for your next hotel booking hotel
chains have been losing customers to
online travel sites such as Expedia and
hotels.com now they are fighting to win
back your direct booking business our
travel editor Peter Greenberg is here to
tell us all about that Peter good
morning good morning
so hotel chains and online travel
websites used to play nice how did we
get well here well they used to play
nice because they had to back to 2008
the recession hotels were very low
occupancy
all the online websites the OTAs the
online travel agencies like Expedia
Priceline Travelocity went to the hotel
chains and say look you're not getting
fill up the rooms let us sell your
unsold inventory and that was a pretty
good idea for them since you know an
unsold hotel room is revenue they never
recouped the next morning so they said
great well before they knew it they were
selling a lot of their inventory so much
so at their markups and with their
Commission's that between 15 and 25
percent of the hotel's revenue was going
to the OTAs so there they got very angry
at one point one chain intercontinental
actually through Expedia out Wow then
they kiss they made up and they came
back in but the point is we're talking
about hundreds of billions of dollars
literally in bookings every year we're
talking about serious money here Hilton
is fighting back now with an ad campaign
called stop clicking around which is the
largest marketing campaign in its 98
year history you bet that's how
significant this money figure is and
what they've done is they've they've
appealed everybody to go back to the
Hilton website basically claiming that
if you do that you'll get a better rate
you'll get free Wi-Fi you'll get other
you get a better rate if you do that
well everything is relative because you
get the better rate officially but the
other thing about it is you also get
points that you wouldn't otherwise get
by booking through the OTAs and in fact
since they've done that Hilton has added
9 million new members to their frequent
stay program so there's some significant
movement there but the bottom line is
the rate as you as you asked is relative
hmm our hotels winning this battle at
all what do they need to do if they're
not well they made some insights I mean
some inroads but it's not about the
hotels winning it's about consumers
winning yeah and it's about educating
consumers as to what their choices
really are when a hotel tells you even
before this war started
you could never get a lower rate that
you get directly from the hotel website
I disagree with that it's called make a
phone call you have a conversation
because each individual Hotel knows what
their inventory is the other thing is
this people think the website is all the
inventory or all the websites do not
even close only about 52 percent of all
available in degree whether it's an
airline a hotel or a cruise line is
actually online so if you do it online
no matter what you do you're
disenfranchising yourself a possibly 48
percent that you didn't know about right
I was actually shocked at Expedia now
has Travelocity and Orbitz under their
umbrella Expedia is the big is the big
bird here they have about thirty seventy
three percent of all the online bookings
and Priceline is number two so yes
because they've got Expedia Orbitz
Travelocity that's all under their
trivago all under the Expedia parent
corporation but here's the thing I'm not
telling people not to go to the OTAs
right I'm saying research look at the
OTAs then look at the other hotel
websites the direct hotel websites and
then when people always forget to do
make the phone call call the hotel
directly and ask them can my kids stay
free can they eat free will you take rid
of that dreaded resort fee can I get
free Wi-Fi and how about free parking
those are questions you can't ask online
and it's not just about the rate it's
about the value but Peter you got to
change consumer behavior pattern to a
certain degree here right I mean travel
websites sort of have the leg up on
technology and that's what that's how
the kids are doing it these days yeah
well all the kids are doing it and
they're still doing it even though the
Hilton and the Marriott campaigns
Marriott also you know pushing book
direct I've made some inroads persistent
consumer habits remain and people are
still going online so I'm just like
waving the flag saying yeah at least
make a phone call is there a way
essentially to play the online travel
sites against the hotel chains in terms
of bargaining for a better deal I do it
all the time and and and they don't like
when I say this but I'll see your rate
on any of the websites and then I'll
call the hotel directly and say I'll
split the difference with you yeah
because it's kind of works every time
well play them off each other get in the
middle of the battle but every once in a
while you can actually get a lower fare
I mean you really can from the website
you just got to be a good comparison
shopper Peter Greenberg with the inside
scoop as always great to see you got